what were some of the things that you
you felt the money should be spent on
and then conversely not spent on like
what were some of the things that you
were surprised that maybe of how
tweaking in the budget here and there
actually benefited you and I am I am
surprised and I'm honored because I have
to believe that it has to do with with
the screenplays that there are people of
the caliber who are in these films that
are willing to work for so little for a
chance that the movie will work and then
everyone gets something on the back end
I'm one of those people who's been
cheated cheated bad word I've been one
of those people who have been the victim
of creative bookkeeping as far as the
back end of films are concerned for
decades we are not going to be that
person I we talk about all the time I
can't wait to call a meeting at the
studio and have dinner Alicia will make
some amazing dinner and will sit there
and will will talk about something and
then hand people checks and they have no
idea that that's what they're coming
here for I want to hand them big checks
because they bet on this horse and they
won and I live for that day
not for mmm how can we how can we cheat
people out of it so we've got folks so
I'll work for it's it's AG ultra-low
budget I mean we work for nothing
yeah we work for a hundred bucks but if
the words are good I'll work for a
hundred bucks never would have before
but I see the kind of people who are
coming to work for us for $100 a day and
we have a great amazing amazing across
the board yeah yeah it's it's it's
wonderful and hopefully I mean that's
one of the reasons why I want I want
them to work obviously I want people to
go oh my gosh Anderson benches is Harold
and Maude for a new age you know I want
that and if they do then then everyone
will will reap the benefits of it but if
they don't they'll still show up and do
another one and maybe that's the one and
if that's not the one then they'll show
up for the one after that and maybe
that's the one they're willing to to
roll the creative dice with us
time after time after time on also I
think what's really cool too is that
we've now developed a family of
filmmakers and they all which I think
it's great with when your regard to the
actors is that they all play distinctly
different characters in each film needs
film it is amazing and it's like wait a
minute it's not the same guy from and
it's just they'll have an accents dress
and it's great so they're getting
fulfilled also you know not only are
they you know enjoying the different
types of projects we're doing but
they're bringing a lot to the table and
getting to show their diversity as an
actor too which is great yeah they know
the actor actors had come in they know
we've got a great guy Duke Davis Roberts
I watched him grow up he's a friend of
my son and we were getting ready to do
he's the guy that runs the drive-through
liquor store in Anderson bench and he
said well what do you want what do you
want I said I said I want what no one
would expect from you and he said what
is that and I said I have no idea work
it out
said you mean I can I can like do
anything I said do whatever it is no one
in their right mind would let you do and
he did that's what I want and that's
exactly what he did and then say he went
so you said can I have like we do like
black out some of my teeth and do this
little greasy hair thing and she said
yeah let's do it
and did it and then just about what
Jason
same thing with Jason and Molly wore
that mullet it did not one there's a
common thread that would Chasen would
kill him in every movie we do that's not
good to kill my son in every movie oh
well did we kill him in the play too did
he die in a Shakespeare he died in there
he did I just everyone thank you doing
play anyway tough tough to be be the son
you